must win situation for anish geary with
the black
pieces and um first we're just gonna
hear from magnus what he said after
winning game three
at least no one can claim that you're
not creating entertainment in your game
same on this no this is um this was good
i think he made a pretty serious
misjudgment at some point when he
uh decided to give up the second bishop
um i feel like as long as there is
nothing concrete for him
in terms of attack i'm just better
positionally and
maybe there was something but he
couldn't quite find it and then you know
it fell apart surprisingly quickly and
is this also a result of you having such
a wide array of opening repertoires yeah
sure i mean
but he was also he was also out for for
a fight when i decided to play something
um
something uh fighting he um
he tried to play for a win as well so
that was fair enough um but i think yeah
as i said position was pretty pretty
normal i think
quite fine for me but then he just
misjudged the position draw with a white
would secure the match does that mean
that we're going to see something a
little more sane in this last fourth
game i will see
good luck thank you
yeah a draw is enough for magnus in this
game are we seeing something sane
something insane but not drawish
magnus definitely keeping the game alive
all the pieces still on the board it's
really nice to see a lot of the top
players when they just need to draw with
white they're quite cynical um i've been
the same myself in the past just if you
need a draw just
drop uh swap of all the pieces
get all the risk out of the position but
magnus okay first trade of the of the
position he's just playing chess and uh
what do you guys think of the opening
here yeah i also think um anish has um
played a line which he has to play um
normally when you fee in chateau early
on it means you're in fighting mode and
you're trying to win as black i say you
know like the king's indian defense the
perk these kind of openings and um anish
has done that and uh
i always prefer white's position in in
these type of structures it feels like
black's pawn
over on the king side has gone a little
bit too far and there's a lot of holes
around that area the white pieces come
into but you need to win you've got the
two bishops that's a good start and
you've got um you've got a lot of pieces
on the board so i think anish has picked
a line which he must have played here uh
yeah so it's it's interesting you're
right just the knight for bishop trade
early on that happened on this square a
few moments ago and this the kind of
double pawns here just it's enough
imbalance to give some hope long term
and simon i know you released a chess
ball course recently on an opening
called the hippopotamus defense and
anishi's trying to adopt a similar setup
right yeah definitely yeah it's released
today actually um i just did the videos
for it uh of this very interesting book
the hippo and um yeah this is this is
very similar to the hippo setup uh
generally black's pawn is one square
back for a while um i know you you play
it sometimes in blitz david occasionally
and it's a it's a really flexible and
kind of fun opening to play um it just
keeps the game alive so
who knows which side black's king's
gonna castle probably queen side where's
the white king gonna castle um it's
quite a lot of decisions to to to make
here yeah and the reason i like this
type of hippo setup
it's just so flexible um the position if
it opens up will favor the black bishops
and any attempt to open up one side of
the board is just met by a block for
example if white pushes here now it will
just be blocked up and uh okay instead
magnus decides to just push his queen
forward um i'm guessing black is going
to do the same
and black will move his queen to this
square and you're right simon it's just
a guessing game um here we go black is
just wallowing in his first couple of
ranks right just sitting waiting and is
white going to be brave enough to castle
this side is that going to be brave
enough to castle this side
yeah plans are so complex
it's a bit of a guessing game yeah
definitely
i mean it's so tense i mean i use this
word a lot but we've seen so many games
that have been
very very just
intense is the right word nervy and uh
here
i mean white has a lot of space actually
black on the other hand is quite cramped
and
i i love what magnus has done actually
look at him he's uh being a real
maximalist
just taking extra space in the center
and
again saying what are you going to do
about your light square bishop which is
bad
and uh you cannot even resolve the
tension that is there in the middle of
the board because then you give squares
to the white knight
yeah
that's a that's a killer blow there
i have to say you think i mean like i'm
just talking about that night you've
mentioned
when i've had this kind of setup as
white i'm never really sure where to put
my pieces and i really like this idea
that magstad of knight c4 to e3
certainly something i'll remember for
the future because the knight on e3 does
seem like an ideal square because
black's pushed his king side pawn a bit
too far so i'm going to remember that
idea for the future get the knight to
that square very nice square for the
night definitely actually this is one
that english grandmaster mark hebdon
taught me when i was i don't know 10
years old he was said if your opponent
goes for this early trade pushing the
pawn forward this is the ideal setup for
white put your knight on this square
united square bishop and queen on this
square and uh this is actually quite a
well-known motif and look at magnus's
time he's barely paused for thought and
the reason this is so clever is as you
mentioned the knights are flexible but
also you this kind of diagonal is so
important for white black if he could
would love to castle on this side of the
board but he never can because now a
pawn would drop and this is why you kind
of leave your queen and bishop on this
diagonal eyeing up this pawn and you're
just tying down black's rook and uh yeah
in the current position this one if
black's king can't castle this side
definitely doesn't want to cast on the
other side white has a semi-open file
here then what is anish actually doing
he's just completely stuck and yeah as
long as you keep this battery black can
barely
make a move at some point we'll see
white push this pawn forward
go even more maximalist often in these
types of positions white can castle this
side if he needs to but one other plan
that i've seen is to kind of put the
king on this square uh just kind of put
leave your rooks in the corner because
white's rooks are actually great
on these two
lines so yeah i love your king run i was
actually thinking that black could try
and do the same but then i was like no
you should
maybe you can yeah i've got to put it
somewhere i guess so uh yeah i had a
similar thing and against evan chuck in
a time in a like online tournament and
he did he did he just castled kingside
in the end so but uh um you don't want
to play that but i love how just
remembering one little simple thing like
you said there david the great mark
hedman um told you about this setup can
just cure a whole opening basically if
you know where to put your pieces like
queen there night there bishop there
you're done yeah and actually that's all
you need to remember to get a good
position i love little little bits of
advice like actually don't have to
memorize things you just need to know
that these pieces are doing the good job
and why they're doing that good job and
you can play the
opening probably for rest your life
quite well then yeah so or certain
variations so that's a really nice bit
of advice there yeah that's set up i
mean at the very least you can play your
first what 16 17 moves on autopilot you
like magnus he's barely paused for
thought until this moment
you gain a big time advantage on your
opponents you're more familiar with the
plans than your opponents
um yeah these real nuggets of
information they do exist in different
systems uh different opening systems
when it's not necessarily about
calculation when it's just about peace
placement and i think that's why i'm
attracted to
those types of uh those types of
early middle game position just all
about planning knowing where the pieces
belong and then you work out the order
you go from there
and magnus look at the computer the
evaluation bar it's already all up in
his favor there's no big breakthrough
there's no immediate win but just
because he's put his pieces on good
squares more harmonious squares than
black he has a big advantage already
yeah so what is a niche sort of thinking
and feeling sitting here he knows he
needs to win this game he knows he's
playing world number one and obviously
he's seeing the board is he getting
stressed that he's going to lose this
much i think he's maybe not even
thinking about losing i mean i think
he's just in survival mode he recognizes
that his position is bad because there's
just no clear thing what to do with the
king
and
you kind of
you kind of lose that kind of thing that
you have to win when you're in that kind
of mode you just okay just survive i'm
just going to make a move and just hope
for the best and then
what happens what happens i mean
it does look like in this position that
anish has perhaps got some pressure on
the pawn in the middle of the board but
actually when you kind of look deeper
you see like you see that actually you
can't even take that pawn
yeah so for example if white just waits
we mentioned this king maneuver i'm not
sure it's the best move but um yeah your
point your banker this capture only
allows white to jump forward
and uh this is deadly hitting the queen
hitting the bishop
um if the queen moves then you create a
discover check and i think you're gonna
kind of create a huge attack against
this black king there are other tempting
moves for magnus you can bring your
knight forward you can even castle right
now i'm not sure which side this side or
the side both are tempting
as uh yeah as you mentioned that anishi
is basically like a boxer who's just
been hit and he's just trying to dance
around and try to avoid another knockout
in this game if he can keep the game
alive if he can keep the match going um
for example
if the white king moves if black decides
okay maybe he can castle this side as
long as he can survive keep peace on the
board keep the two bishops
there for as long as possible then he
might have chances
20 moves down the line or 30 moves down
the line but right now
it's uh it's bad news for black and
i'm not sure what i'd play here to be
honest i'd be looking in magnus's shoes
as the most uh at the most direct moves
first for example bringing this knight
to attack this pawn uh as javanka always
uh mentions uh and that i've learned
from you uh each move has a consequence
and black's knight doesn't know and does
not protect this pawn anymore
so this would be very tempting um if not
then just castle the king or move it
yeah i mean you could you could also go
for your pawn pushers as well
and start throwing them there's so many
tempting moves
to play here and just putting black off
castle and king's side there yeah now
you definitely don't want to castle into
the eye of the
world
you get too much there to capture and
yeah you'd have to be a brave man to do
that it's brave and there's foolish in
that that one would be it's a fine line
isn't it between uh more foolish and
brave probably yeah
and you called it simon um it's the
dutch player in you you just want to
push your effort love pushing the f pawn
or freddie at the board and i also like
the idea of pushing the e pawn you know
at some point i want to just kill black
basically blow it open yeah cause you
know the black king's in the middle i
know my king's in the middle but my
piece is a better place because of this
lovely positioning of the night that
you've mentioned yeah and um i don't
know i mean like that push at some point
could be scary yeah this looks very
scary at some point if uh if you can
achieve it i'm not really sure what
anish's plan is with this queen move i
guess his whole idea is to capture this
pawn without running into a knight uh
night jump but wow magnus i mean the
safer option would probably be castling
this flank castling this side of the
board but he chooses to castle the other
way and uh
i mean he's not scared the white king
black needs 10 moves to attack it
in the meantime he's going to go for
what you mentioned there simon uh just
he's going to try and explode things
yeah either this way or just by trading
instead of pawns opening up a line for
his rook and still black has this
dilemma he wants to castle this side but
he can never do that because of this
queen of bishop battery black would
simply lose a pawn
what can he do where could he put his
king what i mean what what move can he
play even you know i mean you need to
find a move as black and
finding any move is really difficult
actually here because you can't castle
moving your brooks is pointless
um you can't you can't move yeah you
can't even curl up into a ball and just
go come get me i'm waiting for you to
attack me
here every single move
just has
something negative in its favor
and you capture this pawn in the center
still the same problem exists right the
knight attacks the bishop the bishop i
don't know what you do with it you move
then
bang
check and game over very shortly
i mean this setup i think we all got to
memorize it in this opening uh in the
tori
uh they call this the tory attack this
uh
this opening variation but this set up
for white it's just kind of very nice
yeah
very strong setup yeah it's the dream
square for your pieces
that's beautiful isn't it and this also
makes a nice
little box it does yeah
centralization it's the key right we
talk about it at lower levels but here
it's working at the top level white has
centralized these pieces and therefore
has a decisive advantage very nice
well it's getting dramatic for anish
geary must win situation here in game
four and actually
what a start to the ftx crypto cup
because all the matches that are now
playing game fours there's must-win
situations four for russia and for liam
le to take it to thai breaks aneesh
geary fighting for his life in this
first round against magnus carlsen and a
bunch of moves
watch your moves yeah i was gonna say he
has to use his magic wand here and maybe
he has with that move pushing on the
queen side trying to break open that
area of the board yeah he's waved that
wand but yeah will he be rewarded
because black despite pushing this pawn
he still needs several tempe to break
through to that white king
i mean even if white doesn't touch
anything on this uh on this queen side
on this left side
what is black actually doing
yeah it's not 100 clear but i mean
either i was thinking yeah i was even
thinking you know you're completely
right you know they're not really
careful white as black is doing sorry
but white can even get greedy and just
kind of go well you know it's just a
rook that's coming at my king it's not
that
scary especially when you look at this
beautiful construction of pieces that
are ready to defend the white king so
just greed is good is good
take this pawn uh magnus hasn't taken
that one but uh here for example you
could just give a check the black king
moves and you're right you could at the
very least just park your king on the
square put a knight on this square
you'll never get checkmated yeah but uh
magnus he wants to check mate instead
he wants to finish it off he wants to
see us do that dance
wow yeah okay
you think he's going to power through
now simon or is he going to get greedy i
think he will just go e5 and check mate
i mean like look at the black king
white's pieces are now ready
i mean i'm not even calculating that
move i'm just like you know it's just
such a natural move to play
check with the bishop clearly the line's
open and kill
um it's
probably like you know as simple as that
but you're right this check is the
killer one um you give up a pawn but it
you like you said magnus won't even
calculate this one he'll just see that
okay he's given up a born he'll check
the black king there we go he plays it
instantly and wherever the black king
goes it's going to be stuck in the
center forever and with all the heavy
pieces on the board with all the
ammunition the rooks the queens
eventually this king will
yeah it's just not going to survive and
okay interesting for magnus i was going
to say just open up even more just take
this pawn put a rook opposite the black
king and eventually you'll break through
but no he wants to play for squares for
his pieces
this is instructive he just wants to
break through on the light squares he
wants to get his knight to its dream f5
square
and the black king's already actually in
a mating net
the black rooks can never connect and
magnus i think he's listening to music
but
he's bobbing his head up and down loving
position loving life right now can we
see the players um
music list
be nice be nice if we can say it maybe
future rounds so ask the miami people
yeah yeah they've had a lot of their
hands uh technically
today on day one so we'll give them a
break on day two but on day three we'll
ask them to give us the music list that
would be so cool that'd be good yeah
because i remember last time we could
see the
music list and i remember that liam he
was into classical music he had a lot of
chopin
and i was thinking that was quite a
smart choice yeah
magnus had a lot of like
pop hits yeah like 90s sing-along kind
of songs
it'd be cool
they've all got social media accounts
you can post your spotify list on on
twitter can't you if they all could post
it so other people could listen to their
exactly
quite a nice idea good idea like to
hone in on the power of magnus you know
so you probably know his playlist over
here no i mean i know his taste quite
well i don't know the exact songs i mean
i think he likes to be surprised himself
as well
how about you guys if you could choose
maybe three songs to
get pumped get pumped to just before a
game or during a game
what would be your three desert island
uh there's island discs i think a better
a bit of prodigy would be a good one bit
of fire starter
twisted fire starter
um
maybe a bit of uh yeah something like
that i don't know yeah i'll just pick
one that'll do five stars is a good one
yeah for me i really like um
movie music so i would have some hand
zimmer some time you know yeah i'm quite
big ones yeah yeah
exactly build them up yeah and then they
suddenly come to this big crescendo and
yeah yeah
just yeah you feel like you're doing
something special though i like it yeah
that's cool
all right well magnus has been uh
digging some music must be a little bit
annoying for an ishkiri because you can
see magnus from above his computer and
he knows magnus is liking what he's
looking at on the board
any chances for anisha
looking minimal at the moment black is
trying his best to break through towards
the white king but if you look at
attacking pieces black has no attackers
around the white king
and okay magnus doesn't even capture a
pawn back
um i was going to say as well before
this game one thing i would love to see
in the tour is a beauty prize like the
most brilliant game prize for each event
and magnus is trying to achieve that now
um okay a pawn was captured the white
queen swings across and look at the
white knights look at the black king
the white bishop's beautiful the white
pawn on the e6 square
it's just i mean like you said earlier
simon you don't even need to calculate
this type of position put your pieces on
good squares and the tactics will work
in your favor no matter what
i can't really see a move for black
that's the other problem i mean black
can't okay if you have to make a move
like this you're
you're setting the pieces up ready for
the next game yeah let's just push it
back on its starting square
and you still got to finish this
position off but
you know let's
bring the rook into the d6 square bring
the white rook across i don't know it's
only tempting that that looks great i
mean just don't trade off queens that's
the only thing i would say learn from
farouza's mistake against pragnanda
don't trade off queens not necessary
unless it wins immediately which it's
nearly close to doing isn't it you know
i don't think it does but it's very
close
even if he might do it i don't know even
if he breaks all the roof rules swaps
off the queens
i mean you're attacking has you done
that he's done it
the curse of the commentator comes just
don't swallow and he's done it
but yeah
that was just unfortunate
yeah the problem is black has two pieces
under attack if you save the rook and
continue uh defending your bishop i mean
white can win in a few ways here i think
you could win with giving a check but
for example even if you trade off here
and then just plant your knight into its
dream square you're just going to push
this pawn forward and it will become a
queen
again black is completely stuck black
just cannot move
and there we go magnus plays the simple
approach he trades off and this pawn is
going to win the game uh we'll see a
result any moment this pawn will step
forward um you're actually threatening
for example if black moves a pawn you're
threatening to give a check with your
rook
and uh here
sorry i'm just being lovely flashy here
fork and the king moves you make a new
queen and you checkmate shortly
we'll see anishkari resign right now um
it's just complete domination magnus
he's up to his level the last two games
yeah beautiful game
yeah just masterclass this last one in
the opening this is why we learn
openings just to get a position you
understand well put your piece on good
squares
middle games we come up with plans here
magnus came up with this attacking plan
and then uh yeah just a bit of
calculation and that will finish it off
anisha's not even looking at his screen
right now he's ready to resign
he knows this last game has been
a bit brutal yeah
gonna be interesting too here from
magnus carlsen so in the first major the
oslo esports cup magnus was struggling a
lot with being sick he was a sick guy
the first five days or something of that
tournament
and he didn't win it he was struggling
with his form we know he is out to win
this tournament and what a start to the
day